let's imagine a reaction that is in
equilibrium so a plus b they can react
to form C plus d or you could go the
other way around C plus d could react to
form a plus b and we assume that they've
all been hanging around long enough for
this to be in equilibrium so that the
reaction that goes from a plus B to C
plus d it's happening at the same rate
as the reaction from C plus d to a plus
b now what we're going to do is imagine
what would happen if we disturb this
equilibrium and let's say we disturb
this equilibrium by taking some C and D
out of let's say this was a solution of
some kind so I just one time reduce the
concentration of c and d well that
disturbance first of all is going to
throw us out of equilibrium because now
the reaction that goes from C plus d to
a plus b isn't going to be able to
happen as often because I just took C
and D out they're not going to bump into
each other enough to now form A and B at
the same rate so if you think about the
net Direction until we hit a new
equilibrium this is going to happen less
and this initially is going to be
happening at the same amount so you're
going to have a net Direction until we
hit equilibrium again that goes from a
plus b to C+ D and then if you wait long
enough you're going to hit back at an
equilibrium now let's think about what
just happened we Disturbed the
equilibrium by taking C and D out until
we hit our new equilibrium we have more
we have more of the reaction going from
a plus b to C+ D on a net basis and so
it's relieving it it's relieving the
fact that we took some C plus d out and
it's going to reestablish a new
equilibrium if we took a plus b out or A
and B out or even just one of them A or
B out then you would have the opposite
happen but either way if you disturb it
the system shifts to relieve the
disturbance and reestablish equilibrium
now this principle you might imagine
because it's been sitting here the whole
time is
lal's principle that describes that and
it's not just by disturbing it by
changing say concentrations of reactants
or products you could be changing other
things so for example let's let's
imagine the reversible reaction let's
say a plus b and let's say these are all
gases so a plus b can react to form C or
C could react to I guess you could
imagine break up into a plus b and let's
imagine that these are all
gases so let's assume that's happening
in a container of a certain size and
let's say that I were to shrink the
volume of that container what do you
think is going to happen in that
situation well if I shrink the volume of
that container then you have a situation
where A and B are going to bump into
each other more they're going to collide
into each other more and so you're going
to have a net Direction go in that one
you'll still have some C reacting to
break up into a and b but you're going
to have more A and B reacting bumping
into each other colliding each other to
form C until we hit a new equilibrium
and notice what is happening there when
a plus b reacts to form C it decreases
the number of particles in the container
and it decreases the pressure and So
eventually you're going to hit a new
equilibrium but when you disturb that
equilibrium by changing the volume the
system shifted to relieve that
disturbance in that case the disturbance
was an increased pressure and it
reestablished the
equilibrium let's imagine another
reaction let's imagine a plus b and
let's say this is an end endothermic
reaction so I'm going to treat energy
really as a reactant here just to make
it clear that this is an endothermic
reaction that could form C plus d or you
could have C plus d react to form a plus
b plus energy so the reaction that
starts with C plus d and forms a plus b
in energy well that's going to be
exothermic so let's imagine what would
happen here and let's imagine it's at
equilibrium but then we disturb that
equilibrium
what happens if we disturb that
equilibrium by adding more energy over
here well if I add more energy it's
going to be easier for this endothermic
reaction to occur and so it's going to
disturb the equilibrium in that
direction right over there and so you're
going to have that energy really get
used up to form more CN D you could
imagine the other way what happens if I
were to take energy away away well you
need energy for a and b to react to form
C plus d so if you were to take energy
away then the reaction that starts with
a and b is going to happen less and so
you're going to have a net Direction
with C plus d reacting to form a plus b
until you hit a new equilibrium but the
important thing to realize here is in in
every situation whether we're disturbing
the equilibrium by changing
concentration by changing changing
volume and therefore changing pressure
or you're adding or taking away energy
which you could do in the form of
changing the temperature the system
shifts to relieve that disturbance and
reestablish a new equilibrium which once
again is L shaler's principle